[music]
Thanks everyone. Thanks for inviting me.
Um, so I guess we all know that we are
going through an AI revolution right
now. And if someone asked me what is one
reason for this revolution, I would say
it's scale. The scale of data and
compute.
But what has worked in the field of
language and vision is the biggest
bottleneck in the field of robotics.
Scale is really really hard to achieve
in the case of robotics.
Why? Because first there's no data set
that you can download from internet and
start training your large scale
foundation models. In language and
vision, we have collected data over
decades. Wikipedia, Facebook, Google,
YouTube and so on so forth. But in
robotics there's no such data set. Not
only there's no such data set, hardware
is slow and sometimes very expensive. So
it's really hard to collect data set at
scale.
And let's say somehow magically let's
say some data appears tomorrow. What I
would argue that there are not even
algorithms that can use this data to
scale up robotics foundation model.
This is exactly where skill comes in.
At scaled we are building the world's
first scalable robotics foundation
model.
Why do I call it first scalable? Because
we are thousand times bigger in an
conservative estimate than compared to
our competitors when it comes to the
amount of data that we are using to
build these foundation models.
But there are three features that really
define our foundation model which is
very different from the rest of the
world. First, it's multi scenario.
That means the same brain works whether
you're talking outdoor, indoor, home,
office, whatever scenario you can think
of. It's multitask. That means the same
brain works whether you're talking about
task like locomotion, navigation,
manipulation, assembly, task, insertion
and so on so forth. And last but the not
least, our brain is multi-h hardware.
That means the same brain works whether
you're talking about traditional robotic
arms or this new style of hardware, new
generation of hardware. For example, a
dog robot, a humanoid and so on.
Now, traditionally robotics has been a
very very verticalized industry. What I
mean by that is you first choose a task
that you want to solve. For example,
let's say we want to build a welding
robot. Now you make hardware that is
very suited for that task. You make
software very suited for that task. Now
the great part about being vertical is
that you get first 80% of the
performance very very fast. You get 80%
performance very quickly. But then what
you hit is called something called edge
cases. Corner cases in robotics. These
20% of the times your robot will not
work because of these edge cases. The
problem here is that the amount of data
in one vertical is very very limited.
You do not have enough data to handle
these corner cases.
Nowadays a lot of companies are talking
about humanoids.
Now again humanoids are a horizontal
platform. That means you can use the
same robot in different conditions. But
the AI that they are learning is still
very vertical in nature. That means the
brain that they are training, the
foundation model they are training only
works on their humanoid and nowhere
else.
Now when we talk about scale,
we are not talking about million
examples.
We are not talking about billion
examples. We are not even talking about
hundreds of billions of examples. We are
talking of hundreds of trillions of
example.
If you have to collect 100 trillion data
points, there is no way you can collect
these data points for one vertical
platform.
So for example, for a humanoid robot,
you'll have to build millions of robots,
deploy them for decades before you can
collect trillion of example.
At skilled, we are using a truly
horizontal approach for robotics. We are
using data from any task and any
hardware. We are using the ARM
traditional ARM data from factories that
have already installed these robot for
decades.
But there's another reason why we need a
horizontal approach.
That is safety.
Robots are nothing but machines. And
there's one thing that we know about
machines that machines break down. Your
motors stop working. Your limbs break
down. And as soon as let's say a motor
stop working or a limb breaks down the
hardware is not same anymore. It's a
completely different hardware. A 32
degree of freedom robot becomes a 30°ree
of freedom robot. If you have an AI that
is very suited for that hardware only,
it will not generalize. But because it's
skilled, we are using one brain for any
foundation for any hardware. Now that
brain works even for the 30°ree of
freedom robot.
So I think this is a lot I want to talk
about the foundation model but let's see
what it means in terms of videos. So
here is a teaser video of what we can
achieve with skil brain.
Again our robots are not walking on flat
surfaces. They're walking in forest. And
all the robots in this video are using
skilled brain whether they are
humanoids, dog robot and so on. Same
foundation model for everything. Now
this is a really hard scenario where the
robot has to walk in a forest. There's
lot of debris, there is log, the robot
is able to balance all of that. Again,
our robots are very safe to be around
humans and do precise task. For example,
play placing objects in dishwasher and
do it for very very long horizon task
and some of these uh objects the robot
has never seen before. So it generalizes
to to these different conditions that
you are seeing and very very robust
examples like you can kick around these
robots, you can do anything and they are
still very very stable.
Uh again this is almost magical like not
only the robot can climb hardware but
you can pull push the robot and it will
still continue to do that. That's the
level of robustness that we bring when
we talk about foundation models.
Again it can do reasoning for example to
pick up DVD. It pushes the DVD on one
side and then it picks up climbing steep
hill. This is a really steep hill in
Pittsburgh. Even our videographer fell
down two times trying to shoot this
video doing precise task. For example,
putting AirPods in airport cover
and all these tasks like whether they
are navigation manipulation, they are
being done by the same skilled brain
right now
like balancing out at the last minute
and again you can keep disturbing the
robot. It is robust to these
disturbances that can be created. it
it's able to adapt on the fly to all
these different disturbances as well and
so on. Okay, so this is the model that
we are trying to build a model that
works for any hardware, any task and
just one brain. But when you're trying
to build this foundation model, there
are lots of technical questions to
answer. For example, what is the right
data to train this foundation model on?
Now, when it comes to robotics, we have
lots of different choices we can train
our models on. For example, we can
collect data on the physical hardware
itself. So in 2015 when at Kanei Melon,
we started collecting robotics, robot
data at scale using physical hardware.
The pro about collecting data on
physical hardware. It's a it's a rich
form of data. This is exactly the data
you want. There's no human required. You
can collect data automatically using RL
loops and so on. However, there are cons
that it's really really hard to scale.
Each robot can be hundreds of thousands.
When you have to collect trillions of
examples, you're talking about deploying
millions of robots for decades before
you can reach this. And it's really hard
to hit successes in many cases.
Next we tried to scale the tell using
tell operation and this is something lot
of companies are doing today using lot
and lot of tell operation data but again
we have to collect 100 trillion
examples.
Even if the whole population of earth
becomes contractor for these companies
and start collecting data it will take
decades to reach 100 trillion examples.
So clearly while teley operation is a
good form of data even teley operation
is not scalable. I want to repeat again
teley operation is not scalable to build
a foundation model.
Then in 2022 we tried to scale up using
simulation. In simulation the idea is
you train your model on the simulation
which is very sim different than the
real world. So it's really easy to scale
up. It's easy to get trillions of
example. It's faster than real time. But
the problem with simulation is that it's
really hard to get diverse scenarios.
And next it's very there's also
something that exists called sim toreal
gap. And this sim to real gap the makes
it hard for models trained in simulation
to work in the real world.
Last form of data is videos. Now videos
is a really good form of data. It is
very very diverse. You are collecting
videos in India, China, US, Europe,
everywhere. So you can get really really
diverse forms of data. There's lots of
scale. But the cons is video does not
have enough information. It does not
have force information. So it's really
hard uh to basically scale up with this
un poor form of data. At skilled our
approach is to use all different forms
of data. We use videos and simulation
which are scalable and poor and we also
use teleopen deployment which is rich
but non-scalable. And our approach is to
pre-train using simulation and lots and
lots of human videos and then post-
trainin using teleob data and deployment
data. That makes our models really
really precise. Here is what you get
generalization from. You get
generalization and the ability to handle
corner cases from the pre-training part
of the model. And so you can do very
very precise task.
So here is an example of a precise task
that was pre-trained on lots of videos
but then post-trained on this AirPod
data. Now these are fake AirPods of from
TEU. They don't have magnet so they have
to be really really precise. Now here we
are able to pre-train to such a degree
that we can fine-tune with less than one
hour of robot data. Again, the
pre-training is so good with videos and
simulation that you can fine-tune with
less than 1 hours of robot data. And you
can do it for diverse task, not just one
kind of task, whether they are watering
plants, picking up robots, putting a
pick picking up uh cups and so on so
forth. But this is my favorite task.
This kind of shows you the power of
training foundation model with
pre-training and post-training.
cooking eggs. Really, really hard to
break eggs. My seven-year-old still
struggles to break eggs. But look at
here. The robot is able to break eggs,
whisk it, season it. And this is all
visual. When the eggs are cooked, it
knows from the visual examples that the
egg is cooked and ready to be served.
And we can cook hundreds of eggs every
day. We cook hundreds of eggs which are
really really uh show the performance
that we can achieve today.
But to get the deployment robustness we
basically use more augmentations. So we
take the post training data and we
augmented using the Nvidia Cosmos and
Nvidia Omniverse in partnership with
Nvidia. And so with this kind of
augmentations we are really able to
scale up the post training and deploy
robots live. So here is a robot that is
live went live in Houston Nvidia factory
for GPU task and the goal is to insert
bus bars into the GPU and the robot is
able to do this and scale it up in
Houston fac Nvidia's Houston factory and
achieve it in a cycle time much faster
than humans.
Again this is something which is kind of
unheard of when it comes to these kind
of task like having a cycle time faster
than humans. So it's basically screwing
up all the 16 screws and then the
buzzbar is removed from these tasks.
Okay. So the first question was what is
a data? Next you need to answer whether
you're training an end toend model or a
modular approach. Classically robotics
has been something like this training
different modules for different task.
But at skill we are using an end to-end
approach. pixels as input and outcome
motor commands and all the other modules
are emergent out of the data.
Now I'm sure you are seeing lot of
humanoid videos nowadays. A lot of them
are dancing videos but I want to remind
you this is a much easier task
because here the all the motion is in
free space. It's almost copying the
motion. A much harder task is climbing
stairs because you have to precisely
solve the vision and know where exactly
to keep your steps to climb this. This
is kind of Moravik's paradox. It seems
that the dancing is hard but it's
actually much easy for the robots. On
the other hand, stair seems easy for
humans but it's much harder for robots.
At skil we have one of the best visual
locomotion policy for these robots. And
again robot has never seen any of these
scenes before. It's all the decisions
are being done on the fly. There's a
camera on the torso that is used to get
the pixels and the robot is making the
decisions on where to keep footsteps,
how to balance everything on the fly in
the real time. So you're trying to do
vision and action at 100 hertz which is
kind of what makes this uh training of
these foundation model really really
hard. And you can see it can do these
very very complex terrains and it can
balance itself out on all these complex
terrains and the footsteps are raised at
the right time because the vision lets
you know that there's a new thing that
is coming and you have to balance it
out. Again, this is one of the best
visual locomotion policies when it comes
to climbing stairs. We can climb any
kind of stairs. This is fire escapes.
Now, turns out fire escapes are the
hardest kind of stairs compared to
regular stairs. U which is kind of
counterintuitive if you think of going
up and down the stairs uh with objects
in hand. And again this is kind of
showing that the robot is very very
robust to these different kind of uh
stair locomotion policies and so on.
I'll wait for a second because I want to
show you the next part which is not only
it can climb stairs and so on. It is
very robust to pushes and pulls during
the stairs.
So you can see it. These stairs are
outdoor. Cannot be measured. Cannot be.
They are doing it on the fly. It making
the decision on the fly through the uh
torso camera.
And this is my favorite part here. The
robot is trying to climb the stair.
Someone is pulling it yet it able to
balance itself out and decide. And the
next thing is the hardest. climbing down
and someone pushes you even that the
robot can balance on its own.
But that said, we can also do these kind
of traditional uh blind tasks like
parkour and so on. So here's are some of
the parkour task that our robot can also
do. Uh but again this is a much easier
task than compared to stairs because the
robot is blind in these scenarios.
You can think it climbing up these high
steps again copying the motion and
that's it.
Okay, the last part why Omnibody and
again if you're training specialist
policies and when a robot hardware
changes the specialist policy fail. So
for example here we are tying the robot
leg or one of the knee fails and this
specially specialist policy completely
breaks down because it has not been
trained for this hardware. At skill we
are training a one model for every
possible hardware. So our solution is to
adapt to these changes in hardware via
in context learning and with this our
hardware changes can happen real time
and the robot can adapt in real time. So
this is my favorite example where you
can even take the robot cut its leg it's
still able to balance itself out or you
can have the knee fail it is able to
balance itself out. Again, all these
changes tell you the safety aspect of it
that the robot will be safe even if the
hardware of these robot changes. It's
kind of like crash testing these robot
like the way you do with cars as well.
You crash test them and see if they
fail. So the knee fails, the robot
adapts within milliseconds and able to b
walk in three legs.
What if the robot cannot use front legs?
Again within milliseconds the robot is
able to adapt and walk like a humanoid
because the same model is being used to
both train for humanoids and the dog
robot. Add new parts not a problem.
Again starts to walk with new parts
forces.
You can have like add weights
again. Able to adapt on the fly by uh
using this in context learning. What if
the wheels fail or jam again? No
problem. It starts using the legs and
starts walking like more like a jogger.
Two two knees fail. Not a problem.
Again, able to balance itself out. So at
skill, we are trying to train a brain
that works for different hardware. And
our vision is not a humanoid, not a one
kind of robot, but different kind of
robot making this whole space perfectly
automated. And so here is an example of
our vision where there are different
robots, AMRs, humanoids, uh dog robot,
all these robots working together in
synergy to achieve the task. So AMRs are
moving objects around, humanoids are
doing replenishment with with the uh
placing of hardware.
So it's a mixed fleet of hardware that
can achieve all the task. AMRs are
moving the objects around. There are
these dog robots which are doing safety
violations and so on so forth. So the
idea is we will have a mixed fleet of
robots that will bring automation to
every part of our world. That's it.
Thank you.